lejos de un consenso entreterano y
occidente en la escalada nuclear sigue
en Irán Ahora hay una nueva central que
enriquecerá uranio al 60% la de fortdow
en las afueras de Teherán
como respuesta a la resolución de la
junta de gobernadores la organización de
la energía atómica de Irán ha
incrementado el uranio al 60% en la
central nuclear de fortdown Y es que la
ya tensa relación entre Irán Angelo yea
se ha complicado después de que el
organismo decidiera respaldar una
resolución propuesta por Estados Unidos
a Francia Reino Unido y Alemania en la
que se exige facilitar explicaciones
técnicas creíbles después de descubrir
restos de uranio entre su ubicaciones a
no declaradas acusaciones que Teherán ha
rechazado ya tachado de anti iraníes Y
políticamente motivadas
cómo Irán ha señalado en repetidas
ocasiones la razón por la que las
negociaciones no han llegado a su fin y
las partes implicadas no pueden reanudar
el acuerdo nuclear es obviamente porque
Estados Unidos carece de voluntad
política
eran dispone de una reserva de entorno a
3673 kilogramos de uranio enriquecido en
diferentes purezas del 2%
un 20% y 60 por ciento frente al máximo
de 300 kilogramos y una pureza máxima de
3,67%, permitida bajo el acuerdo nuclear
de 2015 que Estados Unidos abandonó
unilateralmente bajo la administración
de Donald Trump en 2018 y que Irán dejó
de cumplir progresivamente eloía asegura
que Irán está solo a un pequeño paso
técnico para enriquecer uranio al 90%.
necesario para fabricar un arma nuclear
además Irán ya ha asegurado que no
piensa volver a las negociaciones para
revivir el acuerdo nuclear si occidente
no retira las acusaciones en su contra